ils seraient plus de mille mercenaires
du groupe wagner déployés à l'est de
l'ukraine selon le ministère britannique
de la défense notamment dans la région
pour du donbass et autour de quartiers
deuxième ville d'ukraine proche de la
frontière russe et alors que moscou a
annoncé vendredi avoir l'intention de
concentrer les efforts des forces russes
dans le donbass avec le soutien des
forces séparatistes de la région d'après
londres les milliers de combattants du
groupe wagner pourrait être amenée à
combattre dans cette zone fort de 2500 à
5000 mercenaires russes mais aussi
étrangers le groupe wagner est une
société paramilitaires privé réputé
proche de vladimir poutine qui en nie
pourtant l'existence le groupe s'est
déployée depuis 2014 dans les zones de
conflits de la planète où la russie a
des intérêts stratégiques
selon amnesty international il opère
dans une dizaine de pays soutient aux
séparatistes pro russes dans le donbass
reconquête du territoire perdu par
bachar al assad en syrie livraisons
d'armes et combats avec l'armée du
maréchal haftar en libye ces combattants
sont soupçonnés d'exactions au mali en
libye et en syrie